مناورات بكل انواع الاسلحه تقوم بها
القوات الصينيه في محيط تايوان تصاحبها
اختراقات للمجال الجوي لتايبيه بطائرات
مسيره الغرض منها اجراء عمليات استطلاع
دقيقه
الصور الجويه التي تقوم القوات الصينيه
بجمعها قد تفيدها في اي هجوم محتمل لضرب
مراكز الدفاع التايوانيه بدقه متناهيه
الهجوم على الجزيره الاسيويه الصغيره لا
يشكل فقط خطرا عليها بل على المنطقه حيث
قد تنجر بعض دول جنوب شرق اسيا التي
تتنازع مع بكين على السياده في ممر بحر
الصين الجنوبي الاستراتيجي الى الحرب بحسب
مراقبين خاصه مع الوجود العسكري الامريكي
المتزايد في المنطقه
حتى الدول البعيده عن تايوان قد تتضرر من
اي حرب محتمله بسبب الاثار السلبيه
الارتداديه على الاقتصادات الصناعيه
العالميه
الصحافه التايوانيه اشارت الى ان اي هجوم
من القوات الصينيه سيؤثر على قطاع صناعه
اشباه الموصلات الاساسيه في كل مجالات
الصناعه الامر الذي سيؤدي الى خسائر تبلغ
التريليون دولار امريكي
تايوان طلبت من الولايات المتحده تعويضا
نقصي بما في ذلك اعطاء الاولويه لتسليم
قطع الغيار للاسطول الحالي من جانبها
تستمر في تعزيز دفاعاتها وعلاقاتها
الاقليميه والدوليه لتحصل على ما يمكنها
من الدفاع عن نفسها ان اسم ماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات